Hollywood is on the brink of a shutdown
for the first time since 1960 with some
of its biggest actors likely to join a
strike by Script writers The Screen
Actors Guild says deals have not been
reached with Studios and streaming
services they're demanding more
royalties and safeguards around the use
of artificial intelligence to preserve
jobs
an executive producer and comedian she's
been on strike as a writer for two
months and since last night she's
striking as an actor too Gina's in Los
Angeles and with us live a warm welcome
to you so you've talked in the past
about your long battle for recognition
in the UK and then the US you are now of
course successful a well-known actor and
writer so why are you striking
because the industry is changing and uh
and inflation has gone up and our
pay is not going up in line with the
industry changes
um with network TV you're able to get
paid properly for your work and
residuals which are royalties and that
has not happened since the streamers
have come in because they've not
basically been held to the same account
as the network TV so basically you can
make a TV show it can be watched by 50
million people around the globe and that
these streamers can send you a check for
29 cents as a royalty because they there
is no transparency that I have to tell
you how many people are watching and how
much money they're making from the show
so our money has gone down uh
exponentially over the years while the
streamers and this Executives at the top
of these studios are making millions of
billions of dollars and this isn't of
course just about base pay and residuals
or royalties in the streaming era it's
also about getting guarantees that your
work and the work of writers won't be
replaced by artificial intelligence what
conversations are currently happening in
places like Hollywood to safeguard human
Talent
well we're trying to safeguard it was
Cheetos don't seem to be interested in
safeguarding the future of the people
that create the stuff that makes them
the billions of dollars you know we're
not against technology we're against
using our intellectual property to feed
into the sausage machine that is AI you
know to train the AI you're going to
have to feed information into it and
what they're doing is they for writers
specifically they're going to want to
feed our scripts our intellectual
property into Ai and whatever it rubbish
fats out of the other end then they'll
get maybe one writer to make it look
like a human actually wrote it and
that's what they're trying to do so that
you know what all we want is safeguards
of getting at them stealing our work and
not paying us for losing our work to
train this robot in order to put us out
of work and for actors now they can put
the face of anybody on anybody's body to
make any kind of movie so basically
what's going to happen is that there'll
be less and less work for actors and
people's images can be used without
their consent and this is what we're
trying to safeguard against
and there are of course huge
implications also for who potentially as
you say owns the rights to people's
images to their voices but what
specifically in terms of law are you
looking for in terms of safeguards
well we just wanted that if I I don't
want anybody using my image without my
knowledge with I've been at least
enumerate me for that there should be
stuff put in place to stop that from
happening at the end of the day you
can't buy a human the slavery is over so
you can't buy people and use their
images without their consent and that is
what we're trying to fight against and
that we need stuff put in place to make
sure that doesn't happen it's
interesting that you use the uh the word
slavery though you don't pull your
punches in any way I mean what does the
Advent of AI mean I guess for young
Talent are they less likely to be
spotted do you think what happens to the
art of acting and writing
well the act the art will be diminished
uh and it is for the younger actors
coming in if if a computer can
absolutely create the exact person that
they want for whatever movie it is it's
going to it's going to push a lot of
young up and coming actors out of the
industry and for writing the same thing
if if it's an industry that nobody can
afford to be in anymore the at the art
of writing is going to be it's gonna be
gone and basically the only few people
that can work in the industry are
writers who could afford to do it for no
money I.E Tech Bros and trust fund
babies so original voices will be driven
out of the industry original looking
actors will be driven out there in
Industry if they can just make a perfect
robot example of what a human being can
be and so that's what we're fighting
against right I've been fighting against
yeah we want original content original
voices original people
you say you'll say you're not a verse
technology I mean can I very very lastly
ask you do you see any redeeming feature
any silver lining in AI that could in
any way help the creative process help
the industry further forward
absolutely
we're not against technology I'm about
using stuff to help us do things quicker
or more efficiently but not to the
detriment of the people that create the
content if you're going to have ai
writing scripts and AI acting in movies
that is going to be the end of original
you're never going to get another
Breaking Bad you're never going to get
another insecure because original voices
will be gone because it'll all be just
computer generated and you're literally
just gonna have a sausage machine
machine feeding out
amalgamations of previous work and just
re rejigging it for future projects
you're never going to get Original
Stories again and that's not what we
want we can use AI to help us create
better content to help us do things much
more efficiently but not to replace
human emotion and interaction and human
stories
a technological sausage machine it
sounds like a nightmare Prospect Gina
yashere it's been a pleasure to have you
thank you